as you get older your mind goes oh I can
totally do that in your body goes nope
no you can't do that
don't jump over the table don't jump
over it I'm pretty sure I can do this
I've done it I did it back in 2013
actually no I'm 100% right oh good let's
see if there's like a cut or bruise no
no it's like up
I heard of crash cars at the fool that's
my collarbone well that's what happens
when you try to go under percent so he
did you hit the ground like it was a
bounce board at like a gymnasium
first off respect secondly did you break
your collarbone yeah I think I broke my
collarbone press right here
crunchy okay move your shirt back on
I'm really disappointed in myself I used
to be able to do that like no sweat as
you get older your mind goes oh I can
totally do that your body goes nope nope
you can't do that do this is the oh my
god I'm so pissed at myself I'm gonna go
to the ER because I can't move my arm I
felt the crack when I landed my sister
broke her collarbone going over the
handlebars her bike the same way you
went over that table like now the
Adrenaline's wearing off I can feel the
pain coming in and I know that I've
broken something because I cannot move
my right hand you say make a sling take
a big piece of fabric hold it this way
then you go like this and you tie this
together this is the best I could do
dude it's all what hurry get those
cooler that way you can wear like this
yeah how'd you break your shoulder I
just jumped over a table full of guns
yeah that's gonna make a good video at
least
subscribe yes Hey look look at this this
is as far as my hand could go right here
I used to see that I used to be able to
touch this and do this no it sounds
amazing I mean the smoke simulator
inside of me loves the specific like
actual tendrils and wisps of the smoke
that you see one of the ways that I like
to think of when I'm framing up a shot
is adding layers and making a shot look
like it's popping out at you and there's
there's depth like depth is something
that's very important one technique we
use literally adding fog throughout our
scene it just gives us a little bit more
atmosphere and it helps carry the light
and it just makes things look a lot more
cinematic you can see how they kind of
have more of a cinematic feel and I feel
like the fog is what really helps sell
that beautiful light shafts and whatnot
there was though we did a video of a
couple years ago mean police and flooded
the entire studio with fog specifically
so we can have some laser pointers and
actually have like some lines to draw
through the fog you need time you have a
laser pointer you have to have fog yeah
like you can't just use a laser pointer
without pop we're gonna try to replicate
what we captured when we're shooting
tactical reloads only instead of using a
red cam or using a APD the cameras are
obviously different but can we match the
lighting we are gonna try to our plate
two shots one shot is if our actress
Jenna and the other shot is of Freddie
today we're using two aperture lights
we're using the 120 D which is a single
source light and we're using the light
storms first shot we're gonna do is of
Freddie this is when Freddie was
interacting with Niko and he was doing a
I think it takedown of his gun we have a
edge light kicking in the back
his hair which is gonna give us some
nice background separation and then
we're gonna have our fill which is some
CTO coming in from the right-hand side
then we have this which is just gonna
overall just boost our exposure we're
just kicking this right up into the
ceiling but it's kind of mimicking what
these fluorescents are doing just to
kind of give us a little bit more of a
lift and exposure in this entire room
fog fog helps so much if you look at the
shots that we're using right now you can
see like certain areas bloom in a way in
a very beautiful and smooth way to get
that look you use fog and that's
something that I feel a lot of people
especially like students when you're
first starting out you kind of neglect
or forget to use you should definitely
try it the second shot we're doing is
we're gonna be replicating the look of
our female lead red you were going to
play the female lead thank you
so the floor plan is very simple all we
wanted to do was create a nice cast of
light behind her give her a nice halo
around her head fog definitely helped
create that bloom which was something
that we were talking about earlier well
we have a 120 D kicking up through the
ceiling giving us a little bit more of
an exposure game and at our camera is
placed right over here and the 120 D is
directly behind her is bouncing at the
back of her head creating a beautiful
hair light kind of the back light and
then we got a little bit of filling
coming in from our door which is a
natural light and you can see in her
eyes this is what you would call it
catch light her eyes are catching a
little bit of that door for camilanator
that looks identical using a combination
of the single source and our talent I
think it's safe to say that you can
create a very film like image kind of
like what we used with the helium camera
let's make the sequel frame by frame
hey buddy so how are you feeling not
good I mean if I wasn't for these
painkillers which I'm not advocating
drug use but man they're helping me out
right now
bone it's official dude yeah we're gonna
sleep yeah it's straight yellow it used
to be black and blue now it turned
yellow okay so I don't know if I think
it's surgery just yet my doctor looked
at me he's like all right you broke your
bone in two places and this is one of
the most difficult areas to that I
wouldn't say difficult there's a zoo
surgery on but they don't want to just
jump right into you know worst-case
scenario just yet which would be me
having to do surgery on my clavicle
they're gonna wait two weeks and see how
I start healing up before they jump to
that conclusion or that decision so
fingers crossed I don't have to because
I have gotten surgery on my foot before
they drilled holes into my foot and that
was not fun that was out for about a
month well how has this affected my
daily life well it's like I just lost my
right arm effectively I can't do
anything really with this arm I can't
pick things up that are too heavy I can
still like use it but I shouldn't it's
highly advised that I don't use this arm
so I've been using my left arm for
everything and I had right-handed if
there is a silver lining of this story I
will become more depth but using my left
hand I'm learning a little tips and
tricks right now like if you're editing
and you only can use one hand if you
want to screw up through your timeline
instead of moving the whole thing around
you just fold the left mouse button down
and just push with your thumb back and
forth and as you can see you can you can
I think they said a total of like six
six weeks six or seven weeks before I
can actually like move this copying the
Flex part pro meal recipes no joke a
little cigar here I'm working on
graphics today so I'm just like you know
shoot out a little cigar think and
having a kid
this dress does it anyways the point is
is that I'm gonna cut a couple pounds
here I'm gonna go into one of these keto
diets and it just so happens that they
sent along some keto meals that are
ready to go and they were so good that I
ate all of them and now I'm I went to
the grocery store I'm just replicating
the actual meals yeah yeah I've been
having that every single day for lunch
this week this called flexpro meals they
come frozen they have different kinds of
meals that come and they're
well-balanced they're healthy and if you
guys use the promo code to Sam and Nico
20 you get 20% off your first purchase
it's basically ultra ultra low carb
it's called keto k eto because basically
once you'd hit like this like low carb
threshold your body goes into ketosis
basically which is actually like a weird
biological starvation mode that starts
burning off at healthy I already lost 5
pounds
I just need tons of meat and it's great
actually it's literally the steak and
Scotch diet I know that might not sound
the best for your like blood pressure at
all so I try and mix it up with like
some rum I have you made this card now
we're gonna get Adrienne a little
get-well-soon gift because you really
hurt himself and if I were to hurt
myself I would want my friends to get me
a get well soon yeah so golden rule hey
listen I want to see if he can hit that
with with his arm in a sling if he can
jump that oh look at tag on the side of
this building
we're really going hard before taking
these buildings all day just stuff
that's so we made a video cut graffiti
graders reacted like snobbish art
critics we've been around in great at
the graffiti around Los Angeles because
there's a lot of amazing murals out here
like the bombs and tags a lot of people
just throw up that apparently there's
some skill to it or some like that are
based on the comments in that video
they're garbage they look they are
visual garbage if you're gonna put a
piece of art up in the public for people
to look at make it nice so we offended a
lot of people and I'm cool with that
Adrian breakin is clavicle just really
reminded me of how vulnerable our mortal
coils are on this planet we do a lot of
rambunctious stuff in the studio and
just like man it's that easy just a snap
there goes your bone and I think it's
just you know a good reminder that even
if it's casual and it feels like it's a
you know vlog just being kind of made
you know for fun on a channel still
gotta be professional about things
you're going to try to do something
dangerous you warm up to it you put pads
down nice thing about the stunts that
I've done some videos like our first
farcry video there's an end scene where
Eric Linden throws himself up but he
hits the pole and spins and crashes
through a table
it's a kareena so a huge hit I think is
crazy but they practiced they put up
pads first they put pads on the pole he
would jump and bounce on the pads to get
a sense of his momentum and he clear it
where is it gonna land and then little
by little as I pull the stuff out until
he could do this done I think Adrian is
a little embarrassed by hurting himself
like that which is completely
understandable I think he's seen a lot
of pain which is also sucks so I hope it
gets better I think it was a great
lesson for everybody in the office about
how far to take things
[Music]
I'm almost a corner we have a get well
soon card for you oh there and I know
you don't drink a bunch but at least you
can entertain your guests and maybe take
the edge off your pain thank you guys
how's the arm feeling horrible man it
hurts so bad but this made it feel a
little bit better thanks guys
I'm calling it all filmmakers for the
light dislocation Film Festival posted
by our friends at aperture the rules are
very simple create a film that takes
place in one location that's it
easy after you make your film make a
little behind the scenes showing how
you're using lighting tell your story
and create your environment create your
vibe basically just fill us in on
artistry that you are putting in the
lighting of your video and finally
create a top-down floor plan of your
lighting setup submit your videos I'll
have a link in the description and
corridor digital all of us here will be
some of the judges helping to pick out
the winners it's gonna be exciting stuff
hope to see some cool entries and we
will catch you guys later